[Aplausos]
[Música]
rusia fue el primer país del mundo en
crear una vacuna contra el coronavirus
la llamada sputnik v o sea si adelantado
así a toda la industria farmacéutica
mundial y con esta vacuna es con la que
surge el debate podemos fiarnos de la
tecnología médica rusa muchos países
piensan que no
[Música]
para sin rechazar a sputnik
y moscú culpa a eeuu y no brasil no es
el único país ni la unión europea ni
eeuu han aprobado esta vacuna al menos
en el momento en el que hacemos este
vídeo y la pregunta es por qué
desconfían del sputnik v hay razones
médicas o simple y llanamente hablamos
de una cuestión ideológica no sólo eso
la vacuna rusa eran muchísimas
incógnitas por ejemplo esta
putin apoya que rusia renuncia la
patente de su vacuna de kobe pensadlo
bien porque putin quería renunciar a la
patente de su propia vacuna a fin de
cuentas rusia podría ganar una auténtica
fortuna vendiendo su vacuna a todo el
mundo al final del vídeo responderemos a
esta pregunta mientras tanto la gran
duda que tendréis muchos espero vamos a
ver de verdad funciona el sputnik v o
simplemente es una maniobra de
propaganda rusa pues veréis en visual
polític no somos expertos en vacunas así
que nos tenemos que fiar de lo que dicen
las revistas científicas como la
británica delante
en febrero de este año 2021 delante de
público un estudio con 20.000
participantes y demostraron que la
vacuna rusa tiene una eficacia del 91,6
por ciento es decir que en principio
todo apunta a que la sputnik v funciona
sin embargo hoy en día sólo 64 países la
han aprobado y la mayoría están en
latinoamérica oriente medio y áfrica los
países más ricos del mundo siguen sin
fiarse de la medicina rusa y todo esto
puede ser muy sospechoso porque a fin de
cuentas la sputnik v fue la primera
vacuna en ser anunciada
[Música]
en agosto de 2020 cuando todo el planeta
tierra estaba desesperado por encontrar
una vacuna rusia presentó a su flamante
candidata varios meses después tanto
europa como eeuu siguen discutiendo
sobre si deberían utilizarla o no y
muchos pensaréis que hay un doble rasero
a fin de cuentas tanto la vacuna de
facer biotech como la de moderna se
aprobarán a las pocas semanas de
anunciarse cuál es el problema real con
la vacuna rusa porque hay tanta gente
que desconfía de ella hablamos de
ciencia o hablamos de política cómo es
posible que rusia se haya adelantado al
mundo entero incluyendo a toda la
industria farmacéutica mundial y por qué
planear putin está dispuesto a renunciar
a la patente hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
poco de historia
ride ingrassia la primera pregunta que
no estaréis haciendo todos es de dónde
viene el nombre del sputnik v pues
veréis en ruso sputnik significa
compañero de viaje y recuerda los
mejores momentos de rusia
[Aplausos]
por eso la agencia de noticias
internacional rusa también se llama
sputnik news y la vacuna que rusia
quiere vender al mundo entero se llama
la sputnik v por cierto la ub no es de 5
sino de vacuna y diréis pero de verdad
la ciencia rusa es tan importante como
parece y lo cierto es que si por ejemplo
sabéis quién creó el primer reactor
nuclear del mundo pues no no fueron
científicos estadounidenses sino el
señor y un científico ruso
a lo largo de todo el siglo 20 y 21
rusia ha dado a muchos de los mejores
científicos de la historia y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando muchos pero como
es posible no se supone que la unión
soviética era un volador de repente nos
vas a decir aquí fonseca en visual
político que el comunismo funciona haber
tranquilos la ventaja de tener una
economía centralizada es que si el
estado decide invertir en una tecnología
puede poner un montón de dinero de golpe
lo hacían con el comunismo y lo hacen
con el optimismo por eso el armamento
ruso es tan bueno prueba de ellos son
los misiles es de 400 - según dicen los
expertos están al mismo nivel que sus
equivalentes en eeuu y esto exactamente
esto es lo mismo que ocurrió con el
instituto gamma leia
[Música]
recuerdas bien su nombre porque este es
el instituto donde se desarrolló la
vacuna rusa sputnik v es un instituto
fundado en 1891 y nacionalizado en 1919
en occidente se sabe muy poco de este
centro y es normal rusia no es
precisamente famosa por dar a conocer
sus actividades y ser muy transparente
pero lo cierto es que cuando las
farmacéuticas capitalistas se
preocupaban por otros medicamentos más
comerciales y no por las vacunas gamal
ella ya investigaba vacunas para virus
que asolaban el tercer mundo como el
ébola curar el ébola en áfrica es muy
poco rentable para una empresa privada
pero gamal ella no busca el beneficio
económico y eso en este caso les ha dado
una ventaja competitiva enorme economía
estatal una economía de mercado cero
y lo mismo pasa con el dinero al ser una
economía tan centralizada el estado
tiene muchísimo dinero para poderlo
poner donde haga falta y que han hecho
pues para esto entra en escena una
persona con todo el respaldo del kremlin
atentos
[Música]
hablamos de kirill dmítriev ucraniano de
45 años que estudia en las universidades
más prestigiosas de los eeuu pero que
ahora se ha colocado en el bando opuesto
y es el ceo del fondo soberano ruso y si
habéis oído bien al igual que noruega
tiene su fondo soberano rusia también
tiene uno que es más pequeño pero lo
suficientemente grande como para
invertir la friolera de diez mil
millones de dólares para desarrollar la
vacuna que el mundo entero estaba
esperando
eeuu se sobresaltó al oír tumbar al
sputnik va a ocurrir lo mismo con esta
vacuna rusia va a llegar primero kirill
dmítriev feo del fondo ruso de inversión
directa así que con tanto dinero tantos
años y con tantísimo optimismo como
destila este personaje no es casualidad
en agosto del año 2020 ocurriera lo
siguiente
[Música]
putin asegura que rusia tiene la primera
vacuna aprobada contra la cob y 19
habéis oído bien el 11 de agosto la spot
de uva fue la primera vacuna autorizada
en todo el planeta para el uso de
emergencia esta aprobación se dio
únicamente por parte del gobierno ruso y
en base a los estudios de las primeras
dos fases fueron publicados por delante
creéis que todo el mundo vería con
buenos ojos esta autorización pues
evidentemente no está decisión fue
criticada por muchos porque pues porque
aún faltaban los datos finales de los
ensayos clínicos de las últimas fases y
ahí es cuando se iniciaron una serie de
dudas cómo es posible que rusia pudiera
sacar una vacuna antes mucho antes que
otros países en principio más avanzados
como eeuu o reino unido
vamos a decirlo claro en aquel momento
prácticamente nadie se tomó en serio la
vacuna rusa empezando por nosotros aquí
en visual político pero seamos honestos
a medida que se hicieron pruebas se
descubrió que la vacuna funcionaba no
sólo eso que es más barata que las
competidoras fijaos bien una bolsita
incube cuesta 10 dólares esto es un 60%
más barata que la de moderna y un 50%
más barata que la de facer es decir
misma eficacia pero precios más bajos y
sobre todo logística más barata en otras
palabras la sputnik v es la vacuna más
competitiva rusia podría comerse el
mercado internacional si quisiera sin
embargo y aquí llega la primera sorpresa
putin está a favor de renunciar a la
patente es decir que cualquiera en
cualquier parte del mundo podría
fabricar esta vacuna sin tener que pagar
un royalty al instituto gama ley a
cualquier rusia quería renunciar a
tantísimo dinero pues tranquilos porque
vamos a responder a esa pregunta más
adelante antes tenemos que entender el
auténtico problema de la vacuna rosa
la otra cara de una economía
centralizada la pregunta que todos
estaréis haciendo ahora es cómo han
podido fabricar vacunas tan rápido si
seguís visual político ya sabéis que no
basta con tener una buena fórmula para
crear una vacuna también hay que
fabricar la y esto es un proceso
realmente complicado para que os hagáis
una idea a finales de 2020 una empresa
tan grande y contantes en la experiencia
como pzifer decían que eran capaces de
fabricar solamente 1100 millones de
dosis a lo largo de este año 2021 de
hecho las campañas de vacunación se han
ralentizado en europa por falta de
suministros entonces cómo es posible que
de repente en rusia hayan podido
producir vacunas para sus casi 144
millones de habitantes y que además
ahora puedan ponerse a exportar tan
rápido
respuesta rápida no no pueden fabricar
tantas vacunas para que os hagáis una
idea en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo rusia solo tiene a un 6% de
la población vacunada fijaos en este
gráfico israel tiene al 59 por ciento de
su población vacunada eeuu el 37% reino
unido- el 30 por ciento y la unión
europea se encuentra con un 13 por
ciento es decir que rusia está muy por
detrás pese a tener su patente como es
posible entonces que rusia esté tan
preocupada por vender vacunas cuando
todavía no tiene ni para su propia
población pues bien esta es la primera
gran duda que tienen muchos políticos
atentos
seguimos preguntándonos por qué rusia
ofrece teóricamente millones y millones
de dosis mientras no avanza lo
suficiente en la vacunación de su propio
pueblo úrsula von der leyen presidente
de la comisión europea como os podéis
imaginar la propaganda rusa y creedme
hay un montón de propaganda rusa con
respecto a esta vacuna dice que europa
tiene prejuicios contra los rusos sin
embargo muchos países europeos han
llegado a negociar compras vacunas rusas
por su cuenta y creedme en este caso la
ideología y los prejuicios tienen muy
pero que muy poco que ver a atentos
isabel díaz ayuso presidenta de la
comunidad de madrid seguirá negociando
la compra de la vacuna rusa para
acelerar la inmunidad de madrid los que
veáis este vídeo desde españa ya
conocéis a la señora isabel díaz ayuso
acaba de salir reelegida en unas
elecciones donde su eslogan era
comunismo o libertad si hay una política
que podría tener algún tipo de fobia
contra rusia y todo lo que representa
esa es sin duda alguna la señora isabel
díaz hay eso sin embargo en lo que a
vacuna respecta a la ideología importa
más bien poco pero ojo que no sólo
hablamos de negociaciones hay países que
ya han pasado de las palabras a los
sexos y uno de ellos es eslovaquia
[Música]
eslovaquia segundo país de la unión
europea en recibirla sputnik y justo en
eslovaquia es donde han empezado los
problemas porque veréis sobre el papel
la sputnik es una vacuna fantástica pero
cuando eslovaquia analiza las 200.000
dosis entregadas por rusia llegaron a
esta triste conclusión
estas vacunas lo único que tienen en
común con la fórmula original es el
nombre instituto estatal de control de
medicamentos en otras palabras una cosa
es cuando lo pides al instituto gamal
ella y otra muy distinta cuando te llega
para que os hagáis una idea este
incidente de la vacuna ha sido toda una
bomba política en eslovaquia de hecho el
primer ministro eslovaco tuvo que
dimitir por las críticas recibidas por
comprar la vacuna rusa ha sido un
auténtico fracaso de su gobierno además
las autoridades sanitarias de este país
todavía se quejan de que apenas les han
enviado información sobre la vacuna
aquí
y aquí es donde llegamos a la otra cara
de la economía centralizada lo que
podríamos llamar el efecto chernóbil es
cierto el estado ruso puede pagar una
fortuna a los institutos estatales para
que desarrollen la vacuna la pregunta es
quién la fabrica y aquí es cuando entra
un concepto clave en economía la cadena
de valor es decir un científico puede
descubrir una fórmula para fabricar
vacunas pero para fabricar la necesitas
cientos de empresas fábricas de vacunas
proveedores empresas de logística
hablamos de una red enorme de empresas
interconectadas
por supuesto tienes del estado se pueden
imponer controles de calidad y
regulaciones pero es casi imposible
crear toda esa red de proveedores desde
cero y cuando se hace suele salir mal de
hecho eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió
con el accidente de chernóbil chernóbil
tenía una tecnología puntera ya os digo
que los físicos nucleares soviéticos no
tenían nada que envidiar a los
estadounidenses sin embargo había dos
problemas el primero es que los
reactores no estaban pensados para uso
civil sino para uso militar el segundo
era la puesta en práctica porque para
abaratar los costes los constructores de
la central se saltaron unos cuantos
controles de calidad por cierto aquí
tengo que hacer un paréntesis muchas
gracias a operador nuclear por asesorar
me en esta parte le podéis seguir en
twitter por aquí de nuevo una cosa era
la central nuclear que pedía sana
liencres y otra muy distinta lo que te
llegaba y diréis pero bueno es que nadie
se dio cuenta pues probablemente sí pero
vamos a ver quién se atrevería a decirle
al político de turno que ha tomado una
mala decisión si todo esto le puede
llevar a la cárcel si algo caracteriza a
las dictaduras es la falta de
transparencia y eso significa procesos
poco eficientes en la mayor parte de los
casos todo esto se traduce en mucho y
sobrecostes y falta de competitividad
pero en el caso de chernobyl en fin pues
todos sabemos lo que pasó así que
volvemos a la pregunta de antes cómo es
posible que rusia y ha sido capaz de
fabricar tantísimas vacunas en tan poco
tiempo y la respuesta es que no rusia no
tiene una industria farmacéutica capaz
de fabricar tantísimas vacunas en masa
pero a la vez quiere vender vacunas al
mercado internacional
conclusión pues que muchas de las dosis
que se han vendido no han pasado todos
los controles de calidad necesarios y
esto por no decir otra cosa peor sucedió
en eslovaquia y podría suceder en otros
países dicho de otra manera hay un
océano de diferencia cuando lo pides al
instituto gamal ella y cuando te llega y
ya se lo que estaréis pensando muchos ya
están de nuevo los de visual político
criticando a rusia que nos ha pagado
para hacer este vídeo pues no a ver
tranquilos ahora viene la parte
realmente buena de la vacuna rusa ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
porque rusia no quiere patentes
es la única vacuna que cuenta con su
propia página web y hasta su perfil de
twitter perfil de twitter que incluso
llega a poner en ridículo las otras
vacunas es un marketing puro y duro y lo
cierto es que toda esta maquinaria de
propaganda está funcionando
recibe nuevo cargamento de vacunas
sputnik y suma en total 4 38 millones de
dosis contra kobe
[Música]
a la india el primer lote de la vacuna
rusa sputnik v y diréis pero fonseca
porque compran la sputnik y no otras
vacunas esta respuesta se resume en dos
palabras ideología y necesidad tanto
argentina como india tienen lazos
ideológicos y culturales con rusia pero
de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo cierto
es que tanto india como argentina no
pueden comprar las vacunas super caras
de facer y modernas además casi toda la
producción de estas empresas ya está
vendida a los países ricos como la unión
europea israel o eeuu
conclusión que la vacuna rusa les viene
como anillo al dedo además en varios
estudios se ha demostrado que funciona y
existe incluso un caso de éxito real un
país que parece haber acabado ya con la
pandemia gracias a la ayuda del kremlin
y diréis en serio qué país te refieres
fonseca pues atentos
[Música]
san marino primer país de europa en
vencer lakovic 19 con sputnik v pensadlo
bien hablamos de un micro estado de tan
sólo 34.000 personas es decir que es
relativamente fácil fabricar vacunas
para toda su población sin necesidad de
tener grandes empresas farmacéuticas en
el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
el 90% de la población de san marino ya
está vacunada y no han tenido ni una
sola muerte desde el 27 de abril es
decir que en principio parece que está
funcionando y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos vale es posible fabricar
vacunas en un micro estado incluso se
pueden poner controles de calidad para
un lote de 60.000 vacunas pero qué pasa
cuando hablamos de países grandes como
argentina o la india de verdad es
posible que rusia garantice la calidad
de tantísimos millones de vacunas como
lo van a hacer pues atentos
astrazéneca y el instituto gamma leia
firmaron un memorándum de cooperación
con el objetivo de hacer uso de todas
las posibilidades de cooperación
internacional para acercar la victoria
sobre la infección en otras palabras que
rusia pone la ciencia y astrazéneca las
fábricas y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos en este momento extra
técnica pero no se supone que
astrazéneca tiene ya su propia vacuna
porque querrían desarrollar las vacunas
de otros pues si tenéis razón por lo que
parece astrazéneca va a fabricar ambas
vacunas la suya y la de rusia pero ojo
porque esto no es suficiente para que
rusia pueda distribuir su vacuna en
países tan grandes como la india y aquí
llega la respuesta que estabais
esperando la respuesta a la pregunta del
inicio del vídeo porque rusia está
dispuesta a renunciar a su patente pues
por esto
rusia-india pactan producir 200 millones
de vacunas sputnik al año nos ya está
buscando producir su vacuna en masa y
para eso necesita asociarse con cuantas
más farmacéuticas como sea posible no
hablamos de grandes nombres como facer
sino de empresas dedicadas a la
fabricación de medicamentos genéricos
para que os hagáis una idea en china ya
hay acuerdos con empresas para producir
260 millones de vacunas en argentina los
laboratorios richmond producirán 100
millones de dosis
os podéis imaginar si rusia regala la
patente o la pone un precio muy barato
será mucho más fácil encontrar empresas
que la fabriquen sobre todo en los
países de renta más baja a cambio el
kremlin va a tener muchísima más
influencia en zonas como latinoamérica o
la india pero no sólo eso gracias a
todos estos acuerdos rusia también podrá
producir vacunas suficientes como para
inmunizar a su propia población
[Aplausos]
no olvidéis este gráfico aquí podéis ver
como sólo el 6% de los rusos está
vacunado con una población de más de 144
millones de personas rusia necesita
fabricar millones de dosis en muy poco
tiempo es decir que por encima del
dinero de la geopolítica la prioridad
del kremlin es conseguir que se
fabriquen vacunas suficientes para los
propios rusos pensando bien cuanta más
gente esté fabricando las putney cube en
todo el mundo más rápido podrán
conseguir vacunas para sus propios
habitantes pero todo esto sería un tema
mucho más complejo para desarrollar en
otro vídeo porque en lo que a salud
pública respecta la vacuna rusa puede
ser una muy buena noticia para todos
ahora bien su efectividad va a depender
mucho de quien la fabrique habrá países
con laboratorios con mejores controles
de calidad que otros así que muy
probablemente tenemos países donde la
sputnik sirve para tratar con la
pandemia rápidamente y países donde haya
algún que otro problema
[Música]
en cualquier caso todo esto son
suposiciones ahora llega el turno para
vosotros creéis que la unión europea y
eeuu terminarán aprobando la vacuna rusa
en qué medida puede servir esta vacuna
la sputnik para aumentar la influencia
de rusia en todo el mundo podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que aquí en
visual político sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribimos a
este canal y dadle la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]